is bella thorne back on with her ex  Gregg Sulkin I mean dating in Hollywood  is literally the worst thing  [Music]  Bella was spotted taking a casual stroll  with her former flame in LA on Thursday  tere kept things casual as they walked  to Greg soccer match  Bella wore a blue shirt gray jacket  leggings and pink sneakers to support  her ex while Greg sported a bright  orange uniform if I'm get photos out  with somebody like immediately I'm their  girlfriend named Bella and Greg dated  for a little over a year before calling  things off in 2016 but now the two  appear to be rekindling the relationship  this new outing comes just days after  the famous and love actress posted a  bikini snap on top of Greg to wish the  actor a happy birthday she captioned the  cozy pic I love you glad we are here  through thick and thin let's party you  old man